[Music]
and now the only thing better than
macaroni and cheese ice cream is our
jeopardy warm up thank you for joining
us today
let's get to know our contestants today
and we went to the bullpen today and we
got some good ones how about from chula
vista california christian cazares from
the hardin streets of new york
vanessa murphy and mile high city but
always close to our heart nate tannebaum
now we've got about 15 seconds to answer
and again whoever wins tonight takes
home the title of the smartest anchor
ever all right let's get to our question
all right
this hotel and casino celebrated their
55th birthday earlier this week
is it in las vegas oh wait we need time
to work on it though yeah exactly so you
get to write it down here this hotel is
going to celebrate 55th birthday nate's
workshopping this out loud got it
earlier this week
five seconds so it
put down your mark we're going to
confiscate your markers please put them
down vanessa that's enough
thank you
all right nate how about you first all
right i'm going to go with caesar's
palace that is correct great job nate oh
boy he's already great at this game
thank you
let's go to vanessa
and that's uh actually drew a casino oh
wow
uh apparently that's vanessa's casino i
think that's the door to the buffet
this is
of course it is oh boy okay thank you
vanessa that's an excellent effort
christian no failed i said the real the
real
try now see it is a good try i have a
little
advantage because i've been here for 32
years and uh the rio opened in 1989. so
that's 32 years old a bonus question
from nate thank you nate that was great
we've got all sorts of information and
the real
good answer though and vanessa thank you
for drawing us a nameless casino that's
really important so that was great
appreciate that so congratulations to
nate you are our champion with a an
inherited advantage though okay what do
i win what do i win you win high fives
from everyone oh good send
this is the c team today so
great job everyone and you can certainly
join us again at 11 and of course online